There is a new poll about the virus which
shows that Republicans, Democrats and independents
are really living in alternate moral realities
when it comes to corona virus deaths.
Now, notice that I'm not saying alternate
realities in this case.
Everybody was presented with the fact that
at the time.
One hundred and seventy six thousand people
had died of Corona virus.
The poll was done a few days ago.
We're now close to one hundred and eighty
one thousand coronavirus deaths.
But at the time, Republicans, Democrats and
independents were told hundred and seventy
six thousand people have died of Corona virus.
Okay.
Presented with that fact.
Do you believe that is an acceptable amount
of death?
Most Republicans believe it is.
Of course, Democrats and independents don't
think one hundred and seventy six thousand
deaths is acceptable.
So this is a CBS News YouGov poll of twenty
two hundred registered voters.
Margin of error of two point four.
And it found that 57 percent of Republicans
believe 176 thousand Corona virus deaths is
acceptable.
More than half of Republicans believe that's
an acceptable death toll.
Only 10 percent of Democrats believe hundred
and seventy six thousand deaths is acceptable
and only 33 percent of independents do by
a two to one margin.
Independents believe the death toll is unacceptable.
Now, first of all, it's the hypocrisy.
A ton of these same Republicans who say one
hundred seventy six thousand coronavirus deaths
are acceptable thought Barack Obama needed
to resign because two people died of Ebola
in the United States.
There's always a hypocrisy angle.
Let's not make that the focus today.
Secondly, there is a morality component here.
Is it possible that the reason Republicans
think the deaths are acceptable is that early
on the deaths were mostly in blue states with
direct aviation links to China and the other
countries in Europe that were seeded with
the virus early?
Could it be that Republicans are okay with
deaths as long as they're mostly Democratic
voters?
I don't know the answer to that, but it's
certainly possible.
But the really interesting thing statistically
is that you don't have an even partizan divide,
and that could be a factor in November.
And I want to be really clear about explaining
this.
We always expect that all else being equal,
if you have a purely partizan divide in any
issue, you would expect, for example, that
independents would be roughly 50/50 split
on an issue and you would expect that the
Democrat Republican imbalance would be equal.
This isn't super clear the way I'm explaining
it.
So.
So let me give you an example.
You would expect that if Republicans support
something, 70, 30 Democrats would oppose it.
70, 30.
All else being equal.
Meaning if there isn't some other factor to
consider now, there's always some other factor
to consider.
Right.
So when you look at abortion, you don't have
approval for abortion in most cases among
Democrats.
Equal to disapproval among Republicans.
There's religious components.
There's other factors that go into it.
So right now, the country is more in favor
of abortion than they've ever been.
And part of it is you don't have an even partizan
divide.
Yes, Republicans are more against abortion
than Democrats, but it's not to the same degree.
Okay.
Here with this question on the acceptability
of corona virus deaths, the partizan divide
is very unequal.
If we look at the.
Numbers, again, you'll see that even among
Republicans, 43 percent think the death toll
is unacceptable.
It is unbalanced with the Democratic number
showing us that this issue is stronger than
partizanship.
It's still hugely partizan.
But even Republicans, 43 percent of them,
are putting aside partizanship and saying
the death toll is not acceptable, despite
it being our guy Trump, who overside it's
not acceptable.
And then, of course, when you look at independents
who are not 50/50 split, but by a two to one
margin, say this is not okay.
This could be a difference maker in November.
Coronaviruses polling as a top issue for voting
in November.
And even among Republicans, 43 percent say
the results are unacceptable.
If some of those Republicans vote Biden, if
some of them say, I'm not going to vote Biden,
but I'm going to stay home.
It could be enough to push Trump out of office.
Now, of course, on the other side, we've got
voter suppression.
The Postal Service, foreign meddling.
All of this stuff.
So that's why we need to bring out in force
these folks who already Democrats by a 90
to 10 margin, think the coronavirus handling
is unacceptable.
We've got to make sure that they vote.
Last thing, how can Republicans call themselves
pro-life and be the group that by the largest
margin believes one hundred and seventy six
thousand deaths are acceptable?
Just something to think about.